today's topic look we're not we're not
famous
we're not famous but we we've kind of
passed the point where we can just walk
outside and not be bothered at least in
montreal specifically
your personal life becomes the fixation
of certain people
you know and we we were invited at a
school
to do um basically like a talk with
people about like kind of creating your
own platform online and
being you know stand-up comedians who
kind of tour and
we went to the school we did it you know
we were talking to these 17 year olds it
went well
it was an hour top yeah yeah and the
only reason
we ended up going is because one of our
friends who's a comedian he ends up
working at that school as a teacher yeah
so he said yo i love you come talk to
our students i was like man you know
what
i trust you so i'll go and do this so i
leave
i told the students if you guys have any
questions that you guys want to ask you
can ask them now you can actually hit me
up and
i'll basically answer your questions so
one of the students ended up hitting me
up
uh on i believe on messenger no they
posted a comment first
i posted a comment first you posted a
comment posted a comment first on
on on something and then what was the
comment i don't even know what's going
on
one person she tagged another one of her
friend and she said you know she tagged
you
and she said prom oh
really because this happened a year and
a half or two years she said
prom three years ago three years ago a
prom and then her friend that she tagged
replied oh ajo he says yes it's right
there
really okay you gotta freak out okay
the story gets weird so so again this
happened a couple years back right
so then this girl proceeds to drop me a
message asking me a couple questions
about like social media stuff
like that whatever and then at the end
of it she's like hey would you want to
go pro
to prom with me now keep in mind i'm 25.
this girl's clearly in high school
so i said hey i appreciate that but
you're way too young there's no way
that's going to happen
so then she replies with hold up i still
got that dude
so she says i was joking with you huh
probably you have probably have gray
hair you really think you'd get in
so that's what she said to me so i was
like oh and then i replied like i said
best of luck with your prom date search
one day you'll find someone tell your
teacher i said hi
and when he asks what is all that you're
carrying you can tell him
hey teacher i'm holding this l abba gave
me
okay having a good laugh that is pretty
straightforward
no right i don't know how you could see
it at
anything else fast forward a couple
years later i'm not thinking much of it
right i'm hanging out with someone in
the city and we're talking and she
the person i'm talking about i'd
actually gone to that school in the past
and so i was like oh yeah i went there
for a school thing once she's like oh i
heard about that
actually i heard that you had
subsequently asked one of the students
out to prom
and that everyone was talking about how
creepy you were and i said huh
what are you talking about and she said
yeah you asked one of the students a
prom i was like
i was 25 why would i i was like is it
this girl she's like yeah that's like
apparently that girl
[ __ ] hold on i got receipts for you oh
you can send that to me later we will
just keep that i'm just going to show
you right now
boom and then what did it
did
but do you see why i'm heated sometimes
when i get mad about like this kind of
stuff
get it that that's why i don't give you
don't flack no more i don't give you no
five because these things
exist and you know what the thing is
ever i gotta apologize to you because i
live in a bubble
you understand i don't get i don't get
the same thing that you get because i
don't have to
so the bubble is different sometimes
like word maybe you gotta check you hang
out with
no it just be like that and all the
people was like
yo you bashing this you're bashing that
listen what the thing that happened is
that
we're gonna talk about the relationships
that we have we're
cisgendered it's heterosexual people so
we're gonna have
contact with women therefore we talk
about women
and if we get heated sometime it's
because it can become
dangerous that rumor in the
in the time and day that we live now
is dangerous
i got you and who's saying that song
danger i don't think you wanna put me in
the same sentence that's right yo what
are you doing [ __ ]
i thought you was my defense lawyer when
did you turn in the prosecution
your honor i am checked
you can't object that's me anyways and
if i go back on that when you told me
that [ __ ]
you go back on people saying yeah but
you know what fake false allegations
only make up for three percent of
everybody
this is a false allegation this is a
rumor that could become
very hurtful it doesn't count because
the fake allegation the three person
we're talking about is reported to the
police
those that are not that happen in the
workplace is not reported to the police
so it's not part of them three percent
it's still harmful bruh the hint of
impropriety is enough for people to be
in trouble
because people don't want to associate
with somebody who sounds because we know
what people say when there's smoke
there's fire brev i got dms from people
who are writing me
like novels of like what are life
togethers like and i don't respond
you can still see it's a message request
and when you don't respond what happened
they message preach they message people
who are on my friend's list they message
my family they do weird stuff
and some of you might be saying well
listen you make content you're on the
internet you ask for this but i'm saying
at what point when i make content do i
ask
for me to be subjected to this kind of
weird harassment
false allegations all this stuff that i
have not played any part into
do you know this is like part of the
reason why i don't like doing any press
stuff or any media stuff
i try to limit my exposure to people as
much as possible bro you kind of right
like you you started to change my mind
right now right like social media i've
been shutting them down one by one
like instagram is the last one left and
i can't wait to get rid of that one too
because at the end of the day
i can't receive any more dms i just
upload to youtube and i walk away from
stuff as much as i can
and even that who knows but i'm telling
you this if there is a day that is going
to come that where i'm gonna quit all
this stuff
it's gonna be because of that because i
just want to be able to live a decent i
can understand i don't like the idea
that i can't you know like that my kids
might be subjected to stuff or any of my
siblings or my mom
you know i hate that because of this
little little
super tiny fame that i have i understand
britney spears 2007 when she shaved her
everybody was calling her crazy it's
either she's really crazy
or her surrounding is very [ __ ] up
i get it i get it yeah it's unpleasant
bro
it's impo and also because i don't care
about money that much
it makes wanting to do this even less
interesting like if it wasn't for the
fact that people really liked the
content and it meant something for them
i would be gone by now because there's
no incentive yeah there's no i don't
listen 40k a year i'm good i don't need
this money
it's not important to me not not not for
the price it said
man that's messed up so if i didn't
think that this was doing something for
people then i would not do this
why do you know how much i miss being
able to go to a club that i like just to
be able to go and dance and be in peace
be alone
yes but you go you go there to dance and
chill [ __ ] will start to talk
about your last video
yo or or even what not even in like uh
some weird moves come on oh yeah i like
what you're doing and then move on
that's
what we're talking about i'll talk about
you i'm talking about yeah
uh you put this in that and
i'm just trying to sip or drink yo like
okay well leave a comment
yo [ __ ] gotta twist it people think
now because i'm more known
i'm out there dating more it's exactly
the opposite
it's totally uh bruh before i did any of
these youtube stuff i was doing way more
dating
i was way more active way more now i do
nothing last two years
have been so [ __ ] applied it's
unbelievable you know why
because people have that long advance on
you what do you mean well
you meet someone when you're on a dating
thing yeah you meet someone
you don't know them they don't know you
the point is to get to know each other
but now they know so much and they
think they know so much but it's really
that i tried dating
like it was normal for about two years
into this stuff when we were kind of
known here
and and and i had so many awkward
experiences
so many awkward experiences because the
people that come in with uh
okay he gonna be like this and like that
and like that and they like they want to
date you because of curiosity
not because they generally want to start
something with you or they want to
distant that or whatever what not
no curiosity of ooh is it true what the
hell
brev man that could be tiring that's why
i liked online dating so
much because i met i used to meet people
that were completely outside of my
circles a chance for us to just
start from scratch and get to know each
other i had one experience while i slept
with someone
right and then after we're done she's
like by the way i really liked your last
video i'm like when did you start
watching my videos like how do you
she's like oh i've been a fan for a long
time and i was like
it's just weird stuff man it's just i'm
not
doing this so you guys can sympathize or
cry for us i'm just trying to give you
guys like a glimpse into
behind the curtain how weird and ugly a
lot of this [ __ ] is it's really it's
not it's not fun like this face i'm
making right now is like genuine like
like if i could trade it in just be like
anonymous and still be able to post i
would
i take half the money i don't give a
[ __ ] take two thirds of it if i could
just have that i probably would because
i don't like everything else that comes
with it it's really when i started
receiving the dms from random people
fact that you got a dm from a girl that
i didn't respond to telling you to
respond to me
no talking about weddings and
red wedding gowns weddings how many kids
we have what their names are going to be
yup
oh you're not going to answer i'm coming
for you what are you talking about girl
and this is not foreign for me yeah
we're not big we're not even big big
we're not even so oh all this to say i
know a lot of you guys
think you want a popping instagram
following or you want to be
really big on youtube or whatever it is
i'll be honest with you it's it's really
overrated
i'm not saying it's not perks or
advantages i'm not saying it's not a
privilege in some ways
i'm saying the benefits that come with
this phone plan
aren't for me i don't need data i don't
need voice call i just need a phone that
works
so if you want all the extra perks
understand there's a cost you're gonna
have to pay up
and you have to ask yourself is it worth
it i can honestly tell you
if you don't love what it is that you do
for people if your values are in like i
want to stunt and all that maybe it's
for you
but if you're not into that i don't
think you want this it's really ugh
but anyways that's just kind of thoughts
i had
bruff 17 man
it is it's just [ __ ] dangerous 17
it's it's dangerous no
it's just yeah it bumped me out and it
was just super disappointing
but then if you if you yell about it and
you call the person a liar then you draw
more attention to it yeah and then
people like what do you so
it's just like what do you want me to do
man
you know but whatever tell us what you
guys think in the comments below we want
to hear your thoughts
[Music]
the more you talk about the more i get
into fame the more i understand it you
understand that like if
i wasn't in a relationship i wouldn't
date
on tinder i wouldn't date on social
media i wouldn't probably date
i don't i don't think i would yeah i
think i'd be just
me and myself and that's it because
just just the dms that i've been
receiving and i'm just
looking at it i'm like trap
trap yeah trap yeah
try oh yeah oh no that's a trap yeah
this is a buck to hit yeah you know what
was wild